Kim So how we make it work work busy as
how traveling around the world different
city I mean I think you know like as
long as you're secure in the things that
matter the most yeah I mean I could be
away months from someone and then it
makes the time together so fun and so
special and like then you really miss
each other just making making sure you
communicate like the number one thing
that is so important in a relationship
is like a teammate like a team player
and when you find your person hold on
tight and work through things like you
want to go through with someone you
want to know that you can um what else
yeah give it smart hold on I have a
manifest list so it has like good
qualities so I can manifest like a guys
let's see your manifest okay I do think
the list is ever evolving and growing
and I won't stop until until he fits
every single one of those someone who
calms me and drives me wild no airing
out our Dirty Laundry a person who
accepts you and pushes you to your
Highest Potential and manifesting is one
of my talents so watch out world